thanks a lot really loud I'm going to
talking to you guys about some of the
computer vision challenges that we're
facing in our drug discovery activities
at GlaxoSmithKline over the in the UK
and this is going to be a little bit of
a history talk for some of you guys
we've heard during this conference a lot
of the type of stuff we can carry a type
of work we can do with deep learning for
imaging I'm we do work on deep learning
applications internally at GSK a lot of
the methods I will be showing here will
be stemming from more classical computer
vision approaches a little bit of
background about myself I came into the
field rather late I did my PhD in
astrophysics at the University of
Cambridge I'd ended what I refer to as
an academic random walk into the
Institute of molecular and cell biology
in Singapore and two years ago I joined
the GSK R&D hub in Stevenage Chester
data scientist whatever this may mean so
throughout that my kind of leading topic
was was imaging so because I have a show
of hands out who believes that on the
left you have Telescope data go who
believes on the left would have
microscope data good job guys
so you can see even though though the
linear the changing year scale here is
about twenty three orders of magnitude
some of the structures we deal with tend
to be very very similar to each other
and all of the activities stats that we
carry out as part of drug drug drug
discovery and all the needs to improve
on the Equality of data analysis and so
on it's really stemming from the fact
that drug discovery is a hugely
expensive business and this is this
slide gives you some of the stats across
the undistributed seven million hours of
man work and seven thousand experiments
400 researchers to get one medicine to
the market on average getting that
medicine and novel treatment to the
market cost 2.6 billion
dollars and this is mostly because 90%
of the medicines that get to clinical
trials fail and they do not fail because
they don't work at all they fail because
they don't work as well as they do in
animal models and they don't do not beat
the treatments we already have on the
market you might perceive direct drug
treatments you know you might have heard
of placebo trials you don't really do
that for serious conditions because it
would be unethical
you always have to beat the control
group which is on the best treatment
available on the market so I'm going to
be focusing on the on the discovery on
the preclinical stages of of the drug
discovery process which goes from the
initial selection of the biological
target you are after which is connected
to disease if you've chosen to tackle
but the first stage first example I'm
going to give you comes from the lead
discovery phase and this is once we have
selected the condition to treat we have
selected a drug target that we want to
we want to treat we are looking for drug
molecules that actually will do that for
us and whilst there is a lot of effort
going into predictive modeling for for
those intensive and purposes and some of
them or some of the newcomers to the
farmer market are actually like
benevolent AI based in London are
focusing all of their strategy on in
silikal drug design and I believe there
was another talk I wish I had catch that
was speaking on that specific problem
still a vast majority of work carried
out is based on a huge amount of
screening of existing compounds that we
know how we can make and seeing whether
they fix any of the disease we may be
interested in so if you if you think
about it it's a it it's a huge selection
process and you want to increase and
boost the the quality of the filtering
that that you are doing and those assays
or sets of experiments
progressively and progressively more
expensive and more complicated as you go
on a lot of that analysis relies on
what's called high content profiling
where you're imaging imaging Reena you
readout from the experiment is images
you will tag different parts of biology
with fluorescent dyes and you'll
therefore have labeled images
corresponding to biology structures
there was a great talk by David lost
yesterday that spoke about the catechol
challenge on nucleus detection the
reason why this is a very important and
relevant problem is it's the basis of
how all of the commercial pipelines
available on the market are constructed
first you find this the cell nucleus
because it always has one and then from
that you can grow I / on I tessellation
on via watershed to some other some
other marker you can then find your cell
and be able to constrain any analytics
you do to a relevant region of interest
that corresponds to your biological
entity and we are after characterization
of a biologically relevant population
really so overall you quantify the
phenotypes using some sort of imaging
features there's a bunch of software
that already does it on the market and
then you want to discover how do your
chemical compounds modify the imaging
phenotype and the really the motivation
about including doing some more advanced
analytics is that even though everybody
talks about high content profiling not
many people actually do it so this is
from a review paper back in 2014 which
looked at how many papers have high
content screening the HTS ended title
and then on the on the x-axis you've got
how many features of data they actually
look at in their analysis so more than
80% of papers at that point we're
actually only looking at
single feature of the data or maybe two
features of the data arguably this is
not really high content at the least so
the specific biological context I'm
going to be talking about here is
treatment of COPD which is a pulmonary
pulmonary disease it is slowly
lethal there is no treatment at the
moment and GSK is a company that is
leading in the field of respiratory
treatments and this is this is a disease
to the treatment of which we are
committing a large amount of resources
and basically it has been demonstrated
that in this specific disease as well as
in the in the others what you have is
you've got problems with the activity or
the phagocytosis so with the ability of
macrophages your immune system defense
cells to eat up the bacteria that enter
your lungs when you breathe and this
leads to buildup of mucus and blood sort
of slowly growing blockage of your of
your lungs if you physically stop being
able to clear your lungs is to being
able to breathe so we are biologists
develop this rather interesting essay
where we've got the population
macrophages in vitro we introduce one of
the dyes into the macrophages we
introduce a pH activated dye that only
becomes a fluorescent in acidic acidic
environment so and we introduce that
inside bacteria so when the bacteria get
hoovered up and eaten digested by the
macrophages this is when you get the
fluorescent readouts
so you have a direct measure of the
activity of you're interested in of
phagocytosis now of course there was a
bit of a challenge in terms of the data
analysis they were looking at very
simplistic simplistic readouts and they
weren't really interested in doing a lot
of the
they weren't getting out as much as they
could they were looking at just that
sort of population level aggregates as
opposed s at exploring how the
populations behaved I'm not going to go
into too many details about that but
first tip in terms of having a computer
vision project check if there isn't an
already available solution out there and
if you guys do need to work in the
biology space cellprofiler is an
excellent package made by people at the
Broad Institute in the uncarpeted lab
this is a software that is optimized for
kind of classical analysis of cetera
based assays it's got a GUI that mirrors
some of the commercial software produced
by the microscope manufacturers so it's
immediately familiar to your biology
friends because you need a biology
friends when you do any sort of work
like that and it does a good job of
extracting all of the classical computer
visions for features that we're going to
cover later in the talk and it can be
launched from the command line which
means we can deploy that on a server and
this is a very naive bit of code that
uses the Q and the and the threading
libraries so I've got my worker defined
the worker literally grabs the worker
from the Q sets item is is what gets
passed CP Fred will launch the process
and this is just where - and
cellprofiler dot pi happen to live on
the server I was using and it you pass
it crucially you've got that arcs
pipeline that will have that will point
to your relevant config file that your
pal just created for you and then your Q
will for you know for every worker that
- for every worker Fred that you have
initiated it will assign a worker
and then for item and crawler this is
just a simple code that traverses the
directory structure identifies where the
data lives this little does a little bit
of cleanup and gives you the it gives
you the directory structures that you
that you need to pass go and what we did
with that is essentially we looked at
the underlying popular morphologically
distinct populations of macrophages so
over here you can see you've got a bunch
of them that are kind of roundish in the
bunch of them that have fins spindly
those are functionally different
macrophages they do different things in
your for your immune system we've
managed to have a single thanks to those
single cell level features we've trained
a classifier straightforward SVM that
predicts whether this the individual
cell comes from a healthy or a diseased
population and then what you see on the
bottom here this is a mock-up of a
layout of a what's called a well plate
so those are actually you're kind of
paralyzed biology systems where you have
a plastic plate about this big it's got
96 wells on it it's got transparent
bottom so you can do imaging and what's
plotted in the intensity is the fraction
of cells that were given the healthy
label and what is reassuring is that
this actually comes from a plate that
came from a disease model after the
after it has been subjected to our
candidate compounds so in a way you can
measure using gears beyond classify you
can measure the fraction of the cells
that we appear to have a revert to a
healthy phenotype which is what you want
which is what your medicine wants to do
it's to revert back to the original
state pre disease so this is challenge
number one challenge number two was a
different passe which actually broke
most of the commercially available
software because this is a collagen
deposition now saying the reason why it
doesn't work
basically is rooted in the biology so
over here you have collagen fibers which
is the stuff that makes you hair
deposited by the cells inside the well
so all all you have here is the
fluorescent collagen now the problem why
so collagen forms your hair but it also
forms any of the scars you may have in
your body and when you have scar tissue
create it in places where it shouldn't
be that's a condition called fibrosis
there's many different types of fibrosis
depending where it is but this is if you
have it in a crucial system fibrosis in
the lungs fibrosis in the heart that
will pull you we don't want that so we
want to understand how can we modify
this process and so we need a good in
vitro model and we need we need to be
able to quantify that the reason doesn't
work with the classical approaches I
mentioned earlier is over here you do
not really have a direct connection
between the individual cells and the
collagen fibers because the collagen
fibers grow outside of the cells there's
no ability to connect them directly
saying oh this is clearly this
particular cell that produced is
confident fiber but no it's an emergent
structure made by several natan several
adjacent cells so we wanted at this
point to do a analysis pipeline that
just looks at this whole well overall
and crucially we wanted to as a kind of
challenge we set ourselves we have to
completely ignore the intensity because
all they were doing girls how much
collagen do I have how much signal which
is a good first take but we wanted to
see if we can do better well to see if
the texture of the collagen tells us
something about that so this is a peek
into the future extraction function that
is reliant on the Motta's package by the
way spider rock radio which is a really
good numpy optimized for those who are
on the on one of the last talks
yesterday it's a really good really
quick implementation of plenty of the
standard computer vision features I can
highly recommend it
because as you can see it it is really
trivial T to implement and you
I pretty much have single line of code
gets all of your heroic features single
line of code gives you pH tasks features
and the LBP features as well which is
great what on earth are those things and
this is where the history portion of the
talk commenced this heretic fixture
features are pretty much the first foray
into proper quantification of image
image textures all the way back from
1973 and it's basically measures of
things such as correlation variance and
entropy define with response to this
entity called the co-occurrence matrix
the co-occurrence matrix basically tells
you it's if you have P levels of
intensity in your image it tells you how
often they occurred next to each other
for any combination of P for a given
definition of adjacency so the way you
normally deal with those is your protec
harlech means which basically get
measured on the for adjacency directions
down sideways into two diagonals
slightly newer slighting you I say 2007
are part of the free threshold adjacency
statistics so crucially the the key
differences harlech means are
independent of any fractional think you
might have this was purposefully made
for Biological applications for
something where you have an entity tag
with a fluorescent probe so fresh
holding becomes a very natural thing to
do so over here you do you do some sort
of fresh holding and like everybody in
biology
you probably default to Otsu and then
you look at what you already have on the
right for every pixel and has a signal
in it you look at the at these sort of
3x3 pixel set and you use if you look at
this individual pattern and then you
basically have a frequency distribution
of all of the potential
tens of of pixels sort of one one
encoded if you look if you wish and if
you haven't heard of how of also fresh
holding and how it works and hopefully
is well this will play famous last words
No okay so essentially the arts of fresh
holding deals by splitting your image
into the foreground in the background
class and you want to maximize you want
to minimize the intraclass variances
which which also has shown in 979 is
identical to maximizing the inter class
variance between those two it's a very
efficient algorithm that essentially
scans it's an exhaustive search scans
through all of the intensity levels and
finds the fresh holding that is that is
optimal for that for that purpose and
runs very quickly which is always a
great feature okay and this should be
okay
fantastic yay for windows and encryption
cool so whilst my laptop decides whether
they want to it wants to keep working or
not just a quick introduction the final
set of features at the local binary
patterns and the way you deal with those
is you have a set of eight neighbors
that you define the eight cardinal
directions and then if your neighbor is
lower than you then the central pixel
you give it a 1 now you get to give it a
zero if it's higher you give it to 1 and
then you concatenate all of that and you
have a binary digit a binary an eight
digit binary number that you then create
a create a histogram of well you see
essentially select the rotationally
invariant ones cool so it's just my
powerpoint that has crashed so it's not
bits no biggie have got the slides up
never trust you knock them always have a
backup great what will be really funny
if this crash isn't the same slight
transition okay and the video even works
thank you so this is this is the
scanning through the the different
threshold in space that the also does
and you can see the inter class variance
which you're trying to maximize being
computed at every step and once once
this goes to the end you'll see the
maximum will result in your split to the
foreground and the background and
certain applications will allow you to
do multiple also threshold subsequently
if you believe that your foreground
should be further divided hey
conspicuous skip skip ahead because
getting close to the end so essentially
when we when we looked at the the future
space we had two controls there's some
red points or some green points green
points are the ones where collagen gets
deposited but no treatment is presence
or no count no chemical compound that
modifies the process red ones we did not
introduce tgf-beta which is a biological
enzyme called the grow factor which
actually stimulates the production of
collagen and we see that the purple
points which are the compounds actually
have a very significant scatter in the
spa in the space however what plenty of
pharmaceutical assays are designed to do
is they are designed to give you a
response with respect to concentration
you want your drug to have a stronger
effect when you put more of it into the
system so this is what we looked at we
looked at the compound tracks through
that feature space
that sort of how do those behave with
increased concentration and we
essentially saw that it's it's pretty
much revived from the first pro first
principal component and when we just
extracted the first principal component
we compared that to some of our other
methods of quantization on the bottom
and you could see that it was rather
nicely nicely behaved well just were
happy and they decided to stop this
project because because they they were
happy with the output at this point as a
side effect we also we were able to give
them an outlier artifact direction for
free so some of those outliers and
second principal component what cases
where you have hugely bright localized
features and those are not your collagen
this is just a piece of junk that
happened to contaminate the example and
you know if you're doing a manual
analysis you would manually remove them
if you have if you are screening through
70,000 compounds you're probably not
going to be willing to do that
just very quickly there's a bunch of
stuff a bunch of analysis that happens
in the preclinical studies and this is a
hugely entertaining system so on the on
the left side here you see a demo of the
opto select technology by the beacon by
Berkley lights company so what you're
seeing is an individual cell being
rolled around on the surface of the chip
by illuminating the area around it the
way that works is they have a localized
photovoltaic effect and it's the
electric field that gets stimulated
locally that repels yourself now what
that lets them do is in the center here
you have a layout of a chip that
contains something like 1750 nano pens
and you can use those light gates to
grab individual cells that you flush
through the system put them into those
individual pens and they
will happily grow over the couple over a
couple of days why we are interested in
this technology is for manufacturing
purposes
so this broadly speaking two types of
drugs there's your small molecules which
are chemically synthesized there's also
antibody treatment and we cannot
synthesize those we need the proper
biological mechanisms so those are made
in production cell lines in large bio
reactors we want to have them as
efficient as possible and for that
purpose we want to select the most
productive clones so just really quickly
or not so the purpose of that was really
talk we did a small project I'm going to
skim over that was basically tasked with
augmentation of some of the capabilities
of the propriety software that was
delivered with this machine we want to
do we did a couple of things again we
did artifact detection we did so
straightforward machine learning
classifiers or we did all of the
groundwork for machine learning to be
deployed and be incorporated into the
decision-making process on which cells
to export as soon as we get the train
the proper training data which is in
this case features related to production
and this the scale up for that takes
weeks and months so we are not quite we
do not quite have a training set to
train proper machine learning models but
some of the toy ones we have with some
now you work so we have some some toy
models that basically seem to predict
how well behaved and how smooth they the
antibody distribution within those nano
pens is because if you see a lot of this
clumping that could be an early an early
onset or early marker of aggregation
which is a huge production issue this is
mainly why antibody antibody systems do
not antibody cell so lines don't really
work
so that's that's all thank you very much
and if you have any questions about the
work we do one a short question